The next case asks what court should do when two parties interpret a term in a
contract differently.
The case of for gala meant importing versus BNS.
International Sales Corporation comes to us from the Federal District Court in
New York City because the plaintiff,
a Swiss company is suing an American company for breach of warranty.
The underlying issue as judge friendly rights is what is chicken.
The buyer for gala meant importing company announces via its New York agent that
it was looking to buy.
Chickens have particular weights at particular prices.
The seller BNS international agreed to sell the buyer dozens of tons of us fresh
frozen chicken.
Great.
A government inspected eviscerated of two different weights at the set prices,
the smaller birds that it sent at at a higher price.
We're roasters,
quote young chicken suitable for a broiling and frying unquote,
but the larger birds were quotes,
stewing chickens or fowl,
which the Swiss buyers rejected.
They said that the word chicken referred only to broilers and friars and not to
the old hens that seller had sent,
which it called foul even.
So the seller sent the second agreed upon shipment of chicken to the buyer of
the following day.
The buyers then brought suit in the Federal District Court in New York City for
breach of warranty.
We're reading judge friendlies,
findings of fact and conclusions of law from the trial court.
Judge Henry friendly is an incredibly famous judge whose life and death are
memorialized in a Harvard law review essay called the lawyers death.
Uh,
which is included in this module's reading materials.
Judge friendly runs through a number of arguments that persuaded him that the
defendant sellers should win given the two parties different interpretations of
the word chicken.
First,
he found that the seller had written a telegram to the buyer's agent to ask what
chicken meant to which he answered that any kind of chicken was acceptable and
at further clarified that the term was equivalent to the German term Hoon,
which does include stewing chickens.
Each party also brought in an expert witnesses to testify on the meeting of
chicken,
but both side's expert's testified that when they wanted to make sure they
didn't get foul,
they would add clarifying language to specify that they wanted broiling
chickens.
The Department of Agriculture Regulations to which the contract referred also
included stewing chickens among chickens.
Finally,
judge friendly looked at the price that frig offered for the larger chickens,
which was 33 cents.
He found that of all the things that the word chicken could describe,
only stewing chickens had a market price that matched at the time the contract
was made for Galman.
Therefore knew or should have known that it could only expect stewing chickens
for the price it was pain.
Section two oh two of the second restatement of contracts in capsulates.
Some of the principles that judge friendly uses an interpreting the contract.
He interprets it in La in the light of all of the circumstances,
including the prevailing market prices for different types of chicken.
He interrupts.
It's a contract as a whole and tries to determine what the quote generally
prevailing meaning unquote is through the use of dictionaries,
regulations and expert testimony and he examines the extent to which for gallons
acquiesce to BNS is performance to determine if they had consistently objected
to the stewing chickens,
judge friendlies,
arguments about what each of the parties knew or should've known corresponds
with the rule from section two oh one subparagraph two of the restatement party
a.
His interpretation of the contract is binding if party be knew or should have
known party A's interpretation and not vice versa.
In this case the buyer should have been aware and may have actually been aware
that the seller was not quote a member of the trade unquote and would not know
any meaning for the word chicken other than the usual one in a latter case.
Judge friendly suggested that this case should have been decided under the
peerless doctrine.
As you'll recall,
that is the English case where the court said there was no contract at all
because the parties had been referring to different ships by the same name.
Peerless in the peerless case.
There was no reason to think that one party was right in his actual opinion.
In this case,
judge friendly suggests that the correct reading of the word chicken in this
contract includes stewing chicken.
He laid his later decision suggests that this case did involve true
equivocation,
where there is no reason to decide that one party is reading is any better than
the others.
This equivocation a belief would mean that there was no contract between for
Galman and BNS even.
So the end result would not have been very different as judge friendly would've
still ruled for the defendant seller who had reasonably relied on the plaintiff
buyer's promise.
Another doctrine that lurks in the background of this case is,
is contra proffer endom that we read ambiguous contractual terms against the
party who drafted them here for Galman chose the word chicken in phrasing it's
order and BNS reasonably provided something that coincided with an objective
meaning of chicken.
The drafter would have the burden of showing that this was within the meaning of
the contract and it did not successfully do this,
uh,
in this case.
So here's a quiz.
Now imagine that a young person contracts to buy 100 mice from an older person.
When the older person delivers 100 live mice instead of 100 computer mice,
the young person sues for breach of contract,
which pieces of evidence would help the older person's case?
Well,
a and c would help the older person's case see falls under section two o to the
young person should have known that the older person interpreted the agreement
differently.
A provides and in light of all the circumstances argument that the older person
reasonably concluded that the young person wanted live mice to feed his cats.
B And d both provide reasons why the older person should have known that
computer mice were wanted and so they would help the younger person's case.
Instead,
we have seen the courts use a variety of methods to determine the meaning of
contract provisions,
dictionaries,
regulations,
maxims of interpretations such as Contra Proffer,
Endone and the economic context are just a few examples where two parties
disagree.
Section two oh one sub paragraph.
Two of the restatement says that the courts can look at which party knew.
The other is interpretation.
If a party knew the other party interpreted the contract differently,
they'll lose because they should have clarified the contract.